both: OH, HELLO.
- OF COURSE,
I'M GIL FAIZON.
- AND I'M GEORGE ST. GEEGLAND.
- AND THIS IS A NEW EPISODE
OF "TOO MUCH TUNA."
- SO WHAT'S UP,
ALL YOU TUNAHEADS?
- LET'S TAKE A MOMENT
OF SILENCE
FOR OUR PRODUCER,
LEN LUMPKIN,
WHO DIED THIS WEEK
FROM CAR ACCIDENT
FOLLOWED BY ANEURYSM.
- HE WAS IN A CAR ACCIDENT.
HE WAS OKAY.
A MOMENT OF SILENCE.
[slurping]
BECAUSE LEN'S DEAD,
WE HAVE A NEW CREW MEMBER
TAKING HIS PLACE.
NORA?
- NORA.
- IT'S ACT--
IT'S ACTUALLY "NOAH."
- OH, YOU'RE NOAH.
SOMETIMES GIL'S GONNA HAVE
DEMENTIA,
AND YOU'RE GONNA HAVE
TO SHAVE HIM IN THE MORNING.
- YEAH, I GOTTA DO IT
IN BATHTUB
SO I CAN LOOK
AT THE HAIRS FLOAT.
- THIS WEEK'S EPISODE
IS GONNA BE EXTRA SPECIAL.
- YEAH, 'CAUSE SOMEBODY'S
GETTING PRANKED,
AND THEY DON'T KNOW
ABOUT IT YET.
- SO TUNA IN TO SEE WHO'S
GONNA GET PRANKED.
HOW ODD, IT'S JUST THE TWO OF US
SITTING HERE
ON "TOO MUCH TUNA."
- YEAH, WITH NOBODY...
GETTING PRANKED.
- WELL, AS LONG
AS WE'RE WAITING FOR, UH...
OUR PRANK GUEST, WHY DON'T WE
HAVE A LITTLE LUNCH?
OH, HO, HO!
WHAT IS THE MEANING OF THIS?
- THIS IS SUPPOSED TO GO
IN FRONT OF HIM.
- WHAT IS THIS?
NO, I DON'T WANT--
- NO, I THINK
THERE'S A PROBLEM HERE
'CAUSE THIS IS SUPPOSED
TO BE...
- NO, ACTUALLY, I THINK...
- IN FRONT OF HIM.
- THIS IS SUPPOSED TO BE
OVER HERE.
- BECAUSE IF YOU LOOK
AT THIS--
I'M NOT SUPPOSED TO HAVE THIS
[mutters] IN ONE WEEK.
- THIS IS NOT FOR ME.
I DON'T WANT THIS.
IDA, THIS IS NOT SUPPOSED
TO BE HERE.
I'M NOT GONNA HAVE IT.
- I'M SUPPOSED TO GIVE THIS
TO HIM.
- YOU'VE GOT TOO MUCH TUNA.
- WHAT DO YOU THINK'S HAPPENING
THE OTHER WAY AROUND HERE?
- NOTHING'S HAPPENING.
I GOT A POTATO BUN.
THERE'S SOMETHING UNDER IT.
I'M NOT EVEN LOOKING.
I DON'T EVEN CARE.
- THE TABLES HAVE TURNED,
FRIEND.
THERE'S A WHOLE MOUNTAIN
OF TUNA FISH
RIGHT IN FRONT OF YOU.
LOOK WHAT'S HAPPENED HERE.
- UH-OH.
- IT'S--
IT'S TOO MUCH TUNA.
- IT'S TWO...MUCH TUNA.
- IT'S--I'VE BEEN PRANKED.
IT'S TOO MUCH TUNA.
- YOU'RE BORN A SCHMUCK
AND YOU'LL DIE A SCHMUCK.
WELCOME TO HELL, IDIOT.
[upbeat orchestral finish]
YES